now you may have heard of catfishing in
regards to the dating world it's when
people hide their identities through
fake online profiles well for one woman
in Alaska falling for a catfish became a
deadly mistake 22 year old Denali
bremmer pleaded guilty to first-degree
murder on Wednesday in the 2019 death of
19 year old Cynthia Hoffman the victim
was found with a gunshot wound to the
back of the head in a river roughly 30
miles from Anchorage prostitute
prosecutors say that Bremer who was 18
at the time met a man named Tyler online
and eventually started a relationship
with him Tyler portrayed himself as a
millionaire and convinced Bremer that
he'd share his fortune under one
condition she'd have to murder someone
in Alaska while Bremer chose Hoffman as
the victim and actually recruited
several friends to help her commit the
crime in exchange for a share of the
alleged cash reward the teens tricked
Hoffman whose family says that she has
the intellectual capacity of a 12 year
old into going on a hiking trip they
bound her feet they bound her hands they
bound her mouth with duct tape before
firing the Fatal shot two of the other
teens involved have pleaded not guilty
to murder charges and await trial as for
Tyler whose real name is Darren
schulmiller and who is not a millionaire
believe it or not he's pleading not
guilty to five murder charges Terry this
is an awful case show Miller he was
extradited to Alaska to face the charges
could he also face charges in his home
state of Indiana as well though yes he
could this was over the internet and he
started the entire accomplice issue over
the internet in two different states
he's in Indiana his accomplice was in
Alaska obviously they all worked
together to do this killing and so he
could be tried in Alaska there's no
death penalty there and he could be
convicted he could be sentenced but then
they could bring him back to Indiana and
there is a death sentence in Indiana and
all they have to do is show he was over
18 at the time of the a crime which he
was and they have to show one
aggravating factor and one of those
factors is that he hired someone else to
commission this crime so he actually
offered these millions of dollars so I
think they could prove all of that so
we'll see what happens but he's facing
charges or could face charges in two
different states and Brian bremmer's
sentencing is August 22nd the three-day
hearing we're going to see if she gets
anywhere from 30 to 99 years in jail
what should we expect from the hearing
well Jesse I think it's going to be a
lot like the Nikki suenzo case where she
had recruited others to commit this
crime or at least her Canadian boyfriend
but this I think is going to be a lot
worse I don't see a lot of mitigating
circumstances here other than she
probably has no criminal record and
um pled guilty but other than that
killing someone who's a teenager the
person had the mental capacity as their
parents did out of the 12 year olds
maybe that's why she was targeted so the
the victim the manner in which it was
done the fact that they were recruited
and it wasn't done for for passion or
love or this but for money from someone
else 30 is the low end 99 is the high
end I would not be surprised if she got
something around the middle 65 to 70
years this is a heinous crime and it
could have come up to being life in
prison for her ultimately within time
you might be right Brian Terry thank you
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice and
foreign